the conjuring the devil made me do it  brings back vera farmiga and patrick  wilson but unfortunately it's missing  its third musketeer  and james wan who directed the first two  films he does not return this time  it clearly shows it has such a lack of  focus unimaginative cinematography  and some bizarre editing mistakes plus  it just feels like this whole universe  has run out of story here  and it has a predictable outcome that  it's set up as a mystery but you're only  given about one suspect and  that's it so it was a huge letdown for  me  and i wish there was more character  death to the side characters  and the love story this time is forced  in it just doesn't work at all i'm  giving this film a 3.8